acting is a serious craft long before
the cameras start rolling most great
actors prepare for their roles by
memorizing lines and conducting
exhaustive research while striving to
perfect every mannerism of the subject
sometimes though this extensive
preparation comes at a cost which actors
went to surprising extremes and almost
died preparing for their roles was the
price they paid really worth it
we'll let you be the judge Matthew
McConaughey following a string of fluffy
rom-coms in the late 2000s it was pretty
hard to take Matthew McConaughey
seriously Dazed and Confused was the one
thing that was passable after they all
thanks man that actually launched my
career after that everything else was
awful McConaughey managed to reignite
his career with a run of critically
acclaimed movies which culminated in an
Oscar win for his star turn in Dallas
buyers club however it turns out that
the actors Oscar win very nearly cost
him his sight after dropping 38 pounds
to play someone suffering from AIDS
McConaughey started experiencing
problems with his vision and consulted
doctors for medical help
fortunately the effects weren't
permanent although McConaughey did
reveal to Metro that the extreme stress
he put his body through was still
affecting his sight over a year later if
McConaughey had continued down the
dangerous path of self-imposed
starvation it's likely that the effects
could have been even more dangerous
Johnny Depp Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas represents an interesting turning
point in Johnny Depp's career and not
just because he could have exploded
literally at any point months before
filming began author Hunter S Thompson
allowed depth to live in his basement to
prepare for the adaptation during his
time in the house Depp taped
conversations smoked cigarettes and even
wore Thompson's old clothes the star has
since shared fond memories of his time
as he got closer I realized that he had
a three foot cattle prod in his left
hand
and a Taser in his right sure just
trying to make friends
however Thompson's act of generosity
could have led to Depp's untimely death
after a few days Depp discovered
something terrifying the cigarettes he'd
been smoking in the basement could have
blown the house sky-high thanks to the
gun powder keg stored down in the
basement beside him this is a very
ominous assignment with overtones of
extreme personal danger I'm a doctor of
journalism man this is important got
done with Daniel day-lewis though now
retired Daniel day-lewis is the poster
child for modern method acting taking
extreme measures to prepare for every
movie role he stars in from refusing to
leave his wheelchair when filming my
left foot to living on prison rations
were in the name of the Father
surprisingly the most dangerous
preparation that day-lewis made for a
role actually sounds relatively safe
while playing the part of bill the
butcher and Martin Scorsese's Gangs of
New York Lewis simply refused to wear a
warm coat while walking around the
wintery streets of New York why the poor
nineteenth-century character he was
playing would have never owned such a
luxury unsurprisingly the threadbare
coat he sported didn't do much to keep
them warm and Lewis caught pneumonia
he even initially refused treatment
because the medicine wouldn't have been
period appropriate talk about committing
to a role
Martin Lawrence comedians always need to
have a joke or two up their sleeve but
the real challenge of comedy lies in the
physicality of the performance
Martin Lawrence learned this lesson all
too well following his part in Big
Momma's House to prepare for the latex
fat suit that the role of Big Mama would
require him to wear lawrence decided to
jog wearing heavy clothing in a plastic
suit in 100-degree heat at the end of
his ill-fated run lawrence collapsed due
to extreme dehydration and heat
exhaustion when he first arrived at the
hospital his body temperature hit a
startling 107 degrees and a ventilator
was required to help him breathe after
he slipped into a coma that lasted for
three days
Lawrence's attending physicians
initially feared that there might be
permanent brain damage but Lawrence
would make a full recovery oh you got
well y'all better get ready to sit down
last long well sweet get up here hey
Matt Damon for his role in the 1996
movie courage under fire
Matt Damon took desperate measures and
underwent an extreme diet to play a
former soldier traumatized by the
effects of war Damon's character had
become addicted to heroin so Damon lost
40 pounds in order to portray the toll
that would take on the human body
unfortunately for Damon his strict diet
took a toll on his health in real life
too four months after filming ended the
star had to remain under strict medical
supervision and take medication for the
damage he'd inflicted on his adrenal
gland
the young actor later revealed in a
reddit AMA that he regretted his methods
and was even told by a doctor that
undergoing the unsupervised diet could
have permanently shrunk his heart if
he'd continued much longer Ashton
Kutcher eager to prove himself as a
serious actor Ashton Kutcher took on the
role of American entrepreneur Steve Jobs
in the 2013 biopic Jobs speaking after
the premiere at Sundance Kutcher told
the audience he felt close to the film
subject to prepare for his part Kutcher
grew his hair long and spent hours
studying tape of the Apple CEO in action
to help him replicate his various
mannerisms it turns out that wasn't
enough before filming Kutcher also
decided to replicate his subjects diet
and only ate fruit nuts and seeds while
this might sound healthy in theory
Kutcher wound up hospitalized for
pancreatitis just a few days before
shooting began Kuchar is not
exaggerating when he says the experience
was absolutely
fine but luckily the actor made a full
recovery Hilary Swank it's not unusual
for actors working on fight movies to
suffer from painful injuries but Hilary
Swank endured a more dangerous wound at
most while preparing for Million Dollar
Baby and it all started with a simple
blister as a result of having to pivot
on her feet constantly during training
Swank developed a blister on her right
foot which she claimed was the size of
her palm during an interview with
correspondent Mike Wallace for 60
minutes Swank explained how it became
impossible for her to train or walk on
the blister so she popped it herself
which led to a dangerous staph infection
that could have been fatal if left
untreated and don't come crying to me if
you get hurt we got a deal
Robert DeNiro there's more where that
came from when it comes to boxing movies
that injured their stars now regarded as
a masterpiece of filmmaking and one of
Martin Scorsese's best movies Raging
Bull suffered a number of setbacks
during production that could have
knocked the film out of the running
before it even got started
actor Robert De Niro transformed himself
for the role of Jake LaMotta training
for nearly a year to embody the part of
a real-life boxer during training he
boxed around 1,000 rounds in a gym to
add 20 pounds of muscle to his frame and
even broke his mentor's rib along the
way however when production in LA was
completed De Niro was sent to Europe on
an eating spree as the role required him
to gain weight so he could play LaMotta
on the decline - after gaining 60 pounds
over a period of four months De Niro
returned to New York to finish filming
but the weight gain came at a price
after his star showed signs of
struggling with his posture breathing
and even talking score says he decided
to temporarily halt production as he
believed DeNiro might be at risk of a
heart attack
[Music]
[Applause]
Christian Bale Brad Anderson s
disturbing thriller was lauded for its
fascinating insight into paranoia and
delusion but ultimately The Machinist
will always be remembered most vividly
for Christian Bale's jaw-dropping
performance to play the part of a man
suffering from insomnia and other
serious psychological problems Christian
Bale dropped over 60 pounds reducing his
body mass to just 120 pounds during a
reddit AMA co-star Michael Ironside
revealed and
more disturbing insight into the
dangerous extremes that bales diet took
explaining how starvation had ravaged
his body saying Chris said can you look
at this and he turned and dropped his
overalls and the muscles in his ass had
literally dropped out of the sockets of
his hips as if that wasn't dangerous
enough bail only had six weeks to regain
his normal weight before putting on the
cape and cowl for his Batman Begins
screen-test
and then just five months more to
develop a physique worthy of the Caped
Crusader
according to Ironside though he didn't
seem to have much trouble managing it
it's not who I am underneath what I do
it defines me thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]